first of all let's just talk about the
fashion of it all very classic very new
and then you went back about the fashion
of it all you have to do something
interesting don't you think
party of the year for television people
and we want to make a splash we love
being invited to the party that's really
what it's all about it's also good to
win though come on let's be on winning
is fun but you know once you win you're
you're on a perch by yourself but when
you're a nominee you're with a whole
bunch of people and you get to be a
little fun gang you know what I mean
yeah what does it mean that for your
longevity that you have been able to
bring a new brand you brought a new
brand to television but you've kept it
going all these years it was new at one
point but now and it's good to grow hold
on TV trust me grow old auntie you know
you know I love doing this I love
television everything I've learned in
this life I learned from television so I
love giving back to television and it's
such an honor to be among the greats and
the people and be part of a
communication and actually just this
idea of what America is we here in this
industry you get to remind people what
it means to be an American what it means
to be a kind person I hear you
what do you think of this new group of
queer I folks oh gosh I think they're
great I was thrilled that they won an
Emmy
last week at that ceremony we won 114
years ago I'm glad to pass that torch on
and I think most importantly is so great
that there's people out there going into
the heartland and having that
conversation and introducing people to
gay people and saying hey we're a lot
more alike than we are different we can
all be part of like ruse that part of
our great country I just want to take
you guys back because my first ever red
carpet experience ended with you sitting
on my lap in the back room do you
remember that do you remember the re
your honor
nothing happened that was yes I think
this is where I have to leave everybody
just want to throw that out there was
just a my first shoot one of my first
shoot 3d HR find out about it don't tell
HR cuz they hold the job it's in there
and everybody tried to crowd in and
Carson said you know what I'm just gonna
sit here on your lap darling
and I was like okay I'm here welcome to
Hollywood why not
have a good evening
[Music]
[Applause]